all right I'm going to go into
presentation
[Music]
mode okay hopefully everyone can see my
screen and hear me um thank you for the
introduction my name is Alex ruier and
today I will be defending my thesis
entitled evaluating micr Shades color
palette accessibility for color vision
deficiency my thesis adviser is Lisa
Carstens and my committee members are
Michael Mooney Annette Totton Steven
bedrick and Tammy
Martin today I will explain the project
provide background
information highlight gaps in the
research review my specific aims go over
methods and Analysis discuss results and
conclusions and finish with the
Project's limitations and potential
future
Direction this project originated from
two key
questions first does the micr shades
color palette improve accessibility of
the plots published in microbiome
literature for those with color vision
deficiency which I'll refer to as CBD
for the remainder of this
presentation and second how can we make
CBD accessible color pellets widely
available to microbiome researchers
creating plots for
publication color vision deficiency
affects approximately 8% of men and 05%
of women there are three types of CBD
protanope duop and
Trope here on the right is a graphical
representation of the three Optical
receptors we use to perceive color and
how each is affected by different types
of
CBD protopia is a green cone deficiency
dutter anopia a red cone deficiency and
tritanopia a blue cone
deficiency cvd can also be categorized
by severity there are three General
severity levels anomalous Tri chromy
where one cone is
mutated dichromacy where one cone is
missing completely and monochromacy
which is full color
blindness on the left you can see this
image of colorful crayons simulated to
represent the proteno view the duop view
and the Trope view both duop and
protanopes have hard time distinguishing
between red and green whereas tritones
have more difficulty with yellows and
Blues
next let me introduce the micr shades r
package which is Central to the project
micr Shades was created by the Carston's
lab here at OSU and it provides two
color palettes one of which was
specifically designed to be cvd
accessible originally this package was
created to improve readability of common
microbiome data visualizations in R such
as taxonomic relative abundant stacked
bar plots but the color palette can be
applied to any type of
plot here on the left is the microshade
cvd color palette which is the focus of
the
project the same palette is shown again
on the right but it's been simulated to
show you how it would appear to someone
with
CBD the top right pallette is simulated
in the dutron note view the middle in
the protote view and the lower right in
the trote
view as you can see each of the 30
colors in the microshade CBD palette are
clearly distinguishable even in in these
three CBD
simulations so why is CBD accessibility
important scientific figures rely
heavily on color to communicate
information in a visual way and when
readers can't distinguish between colors
in a figure it affects their ability to
understand and build upon the work of
others it's important to consider CBD
accessibility in any form of written or
visual communication but particularly in
scientific figures let me give a few
examples let's say you are presenting
work at a conference with an audience of
a thousand people it's likely that
around 40 people in your audience will
have a color vision
deficiency or let's say you are
submitting a manuscript to a pure review
journal for
publication if all three of your
reviewers are male and of northern
European descent there's a one in five
chance that one of them will have a
color vision
deficiency in this project I focused on
evaluating the accessibility of a common
microbiome data visualization the
taxonomic relative abundance St
barplot they chose this Focus for three
primary
reasons the growing popularity of the
microbiome field it's links to several
diseases such as IBS diabetes
Parkinson's Alzheimer's and more as well
as the complexity of the microbiome data
visualization microbiome data consists
of Highly dimensional genetic
information
from the bacteria fungi viruses ukots
and ARA that make up the human
microbiota here's an example of a
taxonomic relative abundant stacked bar
plot which I'll refer to as a taxa bar
plot for the remainder of the
presentation this plot provides a visual
summary of all microbes identified in
each sample and their quantities as a
percentage of the
hole as you can see there's a lot of
information packed into this
visualization
with over 200 taxonomic families
represented here it's almost impossible
to tell which exact family a given color
represents because the shades of each
color are too
similar taxa bar plots play a critical
role in the microbiome data analysis
process however there are a few problems
with current taxa bar plots default
color palettes use either a continuous
spectrum of colors or a discrete set of
colors often with less than 10 colors
options both of these default color
palette types are problematic for taxa
bar
plots continuous color palets make it
difficult to differentiate between the
individual colors from one taxa to the
next when applied to a highly
dimensional data
set in discret color palettes there just
aren't enough colors to represent all
colors in the taxa bar Flo this means
that colors are repeated causing
confusion when reading the plot and
trying to identify specific taxa and
I'll show a few examples
here are two taxa bar plots created in
Python with chime 2 showing 36 different
tax groups the plot on the left was made
using the default color palette which is
discret and contains eight different
colors all colors in the palette repeat
at least four times meaning that each
one is representing four or more
different
taxa the plot on the right was made
using an alternate color palette option
in charme 2 which is
continuous the the individual colors in
this plot are so similar it's difficult
to differentiate between adjacent
colors here's another example of a taxa
bar plot created in R showing 25
different taxa
groups on the left you can see a plot
made with the default color palette
which is
continuous in contrast the plot on the
right uses the microshade CBD color
palette to represent that same data the
circles in these plots are highlighting
some of the lower abundance taxa that
are really hard to see in the leftmost
plot but become clearly visible with the
micr shades color
palette this project had two main goals
first was to evaluate the accessibility
of taxa bar plots in the micr shades
color palette for those with
CBD and second was to prepare the micr
shades color palette as an official
add-on to a popular microbiome analysis
tool to accom these goals we needed to
know how can we assess CBD accessibility
how accessible are the figures currently
published in scientific literature and
would any popular microbiome analysis
tool allow us to incorporate the micr
shades color
palette so there are several relevant
Publications in the
literature Studies by fret all published
in
2015 excuse me
sorry um Studies by FR at all published
in 2015 jambor at all from 2021 and a
recent publication by anger bow at all
published last
year these studies use CBD simulations
to evaluate accessibility and they all
established some level of
inaccessibility and published scientific
images and figures these studies
concluded with suggested guidelines to
improve figure
accessibility however journals seem to
have either not adopted or not enforced
CBD accessibility guidelines in their
Publications our study aimed to fill
important gaps in current research
around CBD
accessibility specifically for more
complex data
visualizations the studies mentioned
don't evaluate highly dimensional
figures like taxonomic abundance stack
bar
plots below is an example of the type of
plot analyzed in Prior studies now
compare that simple plot with the taxa
bar plot here on the right which
communicates much more information and
is inherently more difficult for someone
with CBD to
read these studies also did not provide
a CBD accessible color palette solution
which works for the high dimensionality
of taxa bar
plots microbiome data requires a color
palette with a greater number of
discrete CBD accessible
colors furthermore journals are either
not translating the guidelines suggested
by prior studies into their public
publication requirements or are not
enforcing their requirements when
reviewing manuscripts for
publication there are also gaps in
functionality chime 2's default color
palette is problematic in terms of CBD
accessibility and the tool doesn't
currently have a CBD accessible color
palette as an
alternative Chan 2's taxa bar plot
function does not take custom color
palettes as an argument colors can only
be changed after the plot is generated
using an interacted page which provides
a limited drop down list of chime to
color
options this adds to the current
difficulty of creating CBD accessible
plots within the
tool for this project we set the
following specific
aims first we aimed to evaluate the
accessibility of the microshade CBD
color palette in taxa bar plots for
those with color vision deficiency and
second we aim to prepare the microshade
cvd color palette as a CH to
plugin to accomplish the first specific
aim we surveyed scientists with
experience in the biology or microbiome
Fields asking them to rate the
accessibility of taxa bar plots in both
the original colors and also recolored
with the microshade CBD palette our
study consisted of three cohorts a pilot
group a CBD cohort and a fullcolor
vision
cohort the pilot group was made up of
five fullcolor Vision volunteers
who completed a pre-production version
of our survey and the purpose of this
group was to verify the survey duration
the questions and the overall user
experience for the
survey the CBD cohort included 10
participants who were diagnosed with CBD
and these participants took the survey
without any
simulations the full color vision cohort
included 100 participants with full
color vision who were assigned to one of
five
subgroups these subgroups were either
given surveys without any CBD simulation
in the case of control group or figures
simulated to represent the type of CBD
corresponding to that specific group we
collected responses from participants
with CBD and full color vision
simultaneously here's a visual
representation of the built-in logic
used to separate participants into
subgroups participants were
automatically assigned to either the cvd
or the full color vision cohorts
according to their response to the
demographic question about CBD diagnoses
at the beginning of the
survey those with CBD took a version of
the survey without any simulation and
those with full color vision were
randomly assigned to one of five
different groups protanope dter not
trinot monochrome or
control the survey had two sections
demographic and
evaluation the demographic section
consisted of questions asking about par
participant sex education level and any
CBD diagnoses or other Vision
impairments the evaluation section had
three types of questions for each
scientific figure shown interpretive
questions which had participants
interact with the taxa bar plot by
asking things like does this sample have
a greater abundance of bacteria X or Y
confidence questions asking participants
to rank their confidence level and
accessibility questions asking
participants to rate the figure as
either accessible borderline or not
accessible we provided definitions of
these ratings to ensure consistency
between
participants here's an evaluation
question from our survey showing a tax a
bar plot with questions below asking
about plot interpretation confidence
levels and plot
accessibility the interpretation
question here required respondents to
really slow down and interact with the
figure before rating its
accessibility the survey used figures
selected from published microbiome
literature in January we performed a
literature search in the science direct
database using terms like microbiome
human taxonomy and stacked bar plot from
these results we reviewed Publications
in search of taxonomic relative
abundance stacked bar plots that met our
figure requirements and selected the
first 10 accessible figures
in order to ensure consistency all taxa
bar plots were cropped down to a single
bar in the plot and resized to a
standard height and width these modified
plots were recreated with the microshade
CBD color palette using an automated
plot recoloring function written in
R the survey was created in redcap the
OHSU approved secure web application for
creating and managing online surveys and
databases
in compliance with HIPPA and IRB
requirements the survey was reviewed and
approved by both ohsu's IRB panel and
the redc cap team before
launch we provided survey links to
participants which they used to navigate
to our
survey and all data was collected stored
and managed within redcap to ensure data
security we did not collect any
identifying information from
participants within the survey such as
names or emails
addresses participants were recruited
via conference announcements posted
Flyers tweets and direct email and all
data analysis was completed in
R to accomplish the second specific aim
I wrote a python package that runs
functions from the micros Shades r
package in a background instance of R
and registered the function with the
chime to Suite in accordance with the
chime to plug-in
guidelines this function
includes uh excuse me this wrapper
includes micros Shades functions such as
the color mapping function and the
plotting
function to write the python wrapper I
used commands from the rpy 2 package to
run micr Shades functions in
R this method prevents inconsistencies
between functionality in R and python
with micro Shades because both packages
are based on the code written in
R however it does mean that users will
need both Python and R installed in
their workspace to use our chime to
plugin we chose to integrate the micr
shades color palette with chime 2 for
several reasons chime 2 is one of the
top three most popular analysis tools
for microbiome data with modular
packages for customizable
workflows this tool is free and open
source with an extensive involved
community of users the chime 2 Suite has
comprehens of documentation and
tutorials and importantly for the
purposes of our project chime 2 allows
outside developers to create plug-in
packages overall CH to checked off our
three main
requirements it's widely used in
microbiome research it's friendly to
novice
programmers and it allows for plug-in
packages next I will present the results
of our microshade CBD accessibility
survey
first let's take a look at some of the
participant
demographics over 200 people agreed to
participate in our survey but not
everyone completed the
survey our final data set included 100
participants with full color vision and
10 participants with some type of CBD
who all completed the entire
survey the full color vision
participants had been previously
assigned to five different groups
control proteno dutter Trope and
monochrome this table here shows the
distribution of participant sex within
each group notably the TR toote group
only had 15% male participants a much
larger skew than the other
groups the participants in the CBD
cohort were all male but this was not
surprising as cvd affects males far more
frequently than
females so now let's take a closer look
at the CBD
cohort among the 10 CBD participants 60%
reported a diagnosis of Dutra anomaly a
form of anomalous trichromacy that
affects the red
cone as this is the most commonly
diagnosed color deficiency it makes
sense that most of our participants with
CBD reported having this
type protanomaly is another form of
anomalous trichromacy but this type of
CBD affects the green
cone try to not anomaly one of the rarer
forms of CBD affects the blue
cone one participant reported other and
wrote in red SL green color blindness
which is a generic term encompassing
both deuteranope and protanope CBD
categories next let's go over the
results from the control group and the
simulated groups from the full colision
cohort we start by looking at the
accessibility rate results specifically
the average percent of plots rated not
accessible in each
group these average percents were
calculated by finding the percent of
plots rated not accessible for each
participant and then averaging this
across all participants in each survey
subgroup in figure one we see that
across almost all simulated survey
subgroup participants on average rated
the microad plots as not accessible less
frequently than the same plots in their
original colors we would interpret this
reduction as an improvement in plot
accessibility with the microshade CBD
color
pallet now let's dive a bit deeper and
break these results down by survey
question in figure two we see that the
accessibility rating results varied
quite a bit from one question to the
next excuse
me this figure represents the percent of
participants who rated the plot in each
question as not
accessible now we would expect to see
that the plots in the original color
palette represented here in blue would
more frequently be rated as not
accessible when compared to plots with
the microshade CBD color
palette and several of the survey
questions match our expectations
including questions 1 3 6 and
eight however questions 2 four and seven
did not match our expectations
also please note that any missing bars
in these plots simply represent a value
of
0% so to test our hypothesis we used
mcnear's exact K squar test to analyze
the accessibility rating results for
each survey
subgroup this test takes binary paired
data and compares the number of
discordant pairs between each of the two
categories in the case of our data each
original taxa bar plot is paired with
the same plot in the microshade CBD
color palette and the binary outcomes
are either accessible borderline or not
accessible for example in this
contingency table we see that there are
19 occurrences where paired plots were
rated as accessible or borderline in the
micr shades color palette but rated not
accessible in the original color
palette by focusing primarily on the not
access accessible ratings and combining
the accessible and borderline ratings
together this data becomes
binary this table summarizes the effects
of the microshade CBD color palette on
taxa bar plots in our survey in the left
column we see that the percent of micros
Shades plots rated as not accessible as
well as the percent of plots in their
original colors rated as not
accessible again the majority of groups
saw a red uction in the percent of not
accessible plots when reading those in
the micr shades color
palette the second row of this table
shows results for the all simulated
Group which is made up of the
agglomerated results from the dter not
protanope triop and monochrome
groups we found that the microshade CBD
color palette significantly decreased
the number of plots rated as not
accessible for both the agglomerated all
simulated group and the monochrome Group
which represents the most extreme case
of
CBD next we will look at the
interpretation accuracy results
specifically the average percent of
plots that were incorrectly interpreted
in each
group in figure three we see that across
all survey subgroup participants on
average interpreted the micr shades
plots
incorrectly less fre quently than the
same plots in their original colors we
would interpret this reduction as an
improvement in plot readability with the
microshade CBD color
palette in figure four we see that the
interpretation accuracy also varied from
one question to the next again we would
expect to see that plots in the original
color palette shown here in blue would
more frequently be interpreted
incorrectly when compared to plots with
the microshade CBD color palette
and again most of the survey questions
matched our expectations including
questions 1 2 3 six and
eight but questions four and seven did
not match our
expectations and similar to the
accessibility ratings we discussed
before we also used MC Neymar's exact
Kai Square test to analyze the
interpretation accuracy results for each
survey
subgroup
we found that the microshade CBD color
palette significantly decreased the
number of plots interpreted in correctly
for almost all survey
subgroups finally let's look at the
results for the CBD
cohort at first glance the CBD
participants plot accessibility ratings
shown here in figure five don't seem to
align with the results seen in our
simulation groups in figure five five we
see this unexpected Trend where plots
with the microshade CBD color palette
have been rated not accessible more
frequently than plots in their original
color palettes
overall and again we can look at the
plots or excuse me the results broken
down by question figure six shows the
percent difference in not accessible
plot ratings between the micro Shades
color palette and the original color
palette these results are shown for the
CBD cohort in here in teal and the
agglomerated simulation group here in
Pink as in previous results a negative
percent difference represents a decrease
in the number of plots rated not
accessible and therefore an improvement
in plot accessibility with the micro
Shad CBD color
palette just as with the simulated
results the cbd's co CBD cohort results
varied quite a bit from one question to
the next interestingly the CBD cohort
and the simulated groups are in
agreement in terms of directionality of
change for each question they only
differ in
magnitude in figure seven we see that
for some of the CBD participants the
micros Shades plots were less frequently
interpreted
incorrectly however it seems that the
color palette had no overall effect for
several other CBD
participants for most of the taxa bar
plots the microshade CBD color palette
decreased the number of incorrect
interpretations and like with the
accessibility rating results we see
similar Trends within each question for
the CBD cohort and the simulation
groups we did not perform statistical
tests with the CBD cohort due to the
small number of
participants so to better understand the
variability between questions let's take
a look at one of the survey questions
where we saw those unexpected
results survey question two uh asked
participants to determine if bacteria
eye is present in the sample the correct
answer to this question is no bacteria
ey is not
present with both the simulation and the
CBD participants we observed that the
micr shades color palette worsened the
plot's accessibility ratings but
improved its interpretation
accuracy these observations seem in
congruent until we review the taxa bar
plots and the questions
posed here we see that the plot's
original color palette on the left used
two very similar colors of blue to
represent different
taxa however the blue represented in
this sample is actually bacteria e not
bacteria I the answer is much clearer in
the micr shades version of the
plot and most participants rated the
original plot as accessible believing
the answer was straightforward but then
interpreted the plot
incorrectly when comparing our results
to those of Prior studies the percent of
plots rated not accessible by our survey
participants was Far
higher for example a recent study by
anger bow at ball found that 16% of
scientific plots included in their
survey were not accessible while we
found that more than 30% of taxa bar
plots were not
accessible there are several reasons why
our rates inaccessibility were so much
higher first our study used dimatic CBD
simulations which are the most extreme
versions of each CBD
type second our study head participants
review plots with much higher complexity
with up to 18 different colors in each
plot third our plots did not include any
titles access labels or text
descriptions and prior Studies have
shown that text descriptions and labels
can be extremely important in plot
accessibility finally we designed the
questions in our survey to specifically
Target colors and the original tax of
bar plots which were most affected by
the CBD
simulations this study did have a few
limitations first CBD simulators don't
perfectly reflect the CBD experience
there are a close replication of what
someone with CBD would see but
deficiencies in color vision do fall on
a spectrum and they vary from person to
person our results show that Trends
among the simulated groups at the survey
question level do align with the CBD
group but the differences in magnitude
of change between the original color
palette and the micro Shades resulted in
in congruent outcomes
overall second some survey groups were
underpowered due to the lower than
expected effect size these groups in
particular would have benefited from
either a longer evalu valuation section
of the survey with more taex bar plots
or additional
participants third some of the taxa bar
plots included in the study contained
visual artifacts due to the process to
compress jpeg images for
publication these artifacts appeared as
bands of color which may have affected
both plot accessibility and
readability fourth this study only
investigated the microshade CBD color
palette not the micro Shades package
itself the taex of bar plots in this
study were not created using the micr
shades package and therefore did not
exactly reflect the package's color and
Legend
organization and finally the chime T
plugin has a limitation in that users
will need both Python and R installed in
their computer to use
it for future research I would suggest
increasing the number of participants in
each survey subgroup using PNG images as
as opposed to
JPEG and limiting the variability
between survey questions by generating
the taxa bar plots from raw data with
the same default color palette for
original images and then the micro
Shades package for recolored
images in summary we detected
significant Improvement in plot
accessibility with micros Shades color
palette for simulated groups as a whole
and in particular the monochrome Group
which represents the most EX CBD
simulation we also detected significant
Improvement in interpretation accuracy
with micr Shades color palette for the
all simulated group as well as three of
the four individual groups duop Trope
and
monochrome our control group did not
show a significant Improvement in figure
accessibility or interpretation accuracy
with the mon with the micro Shades color
palette this result was expected as per
participants in this group have full
color vision and they looked at plots
without any CBD simulations thereby
reducing the beneficial effects of the
microshade cvd color
palette with the cvd cohort we did not
see overall Trends indicating improved
accessibility with the microshade CBD
color
palette however we did observe some
improvement in plot readability for the
CBD cohort as a whole and when looking
at the breakdown by question the micr
shades color pellette had a similar
impact on both CBD and simulation
groups in other words questions where
the micr shades color palette improved
accessibility or readability for the
simulated groups the CBD cohort also saw
an
improvement however the effects for the
simulated groups and the CBD cohort
differed in
magnitude these results indicate that
the microshaded CBD color pallette may
have a measurable positive effect on
plot readability
if we were to have a larger group of CBD
participants now I won't discuss my
second aim in too much detail as it's
very technical but I'll give a brief
overview of the accomplished tasks for
this
Aim so we have defined the system
requirements written a python function
which wraps micros Shades functions from
R and runs a basic micr Shades pipeline
we've written the chime to plugin setup
file and create necessary documentation
files for the package and also tested
all python wrapped micr Shades functions
and submitted a pull request to the
micros Shades chime 2
plugin excuse me added a pull request
for the micros Shades chime 2 plugin to
the Carson's lab
GitHub now let me review some of the key
points discussed
today not all scientific figures in
published literature are accessible to
those with CBD but the micros Shades
package has been shown to improve plot
accessibility and readability and
published taxa bar plots with CBD
simulations some types of cvd May
benefit more from the micr shades
package than others and future re
research should include a greater
portion of CBD participants to better
understand
this chime 2 is an ideal platform for
our new micr shades package to maximize
usage and awareness in the microbiome
research community
wanted to give a big thank you to my
thesis adviser Lisa Carstens for helping
me develop and complete this project and
providing guidance along the way thank
you also to my thesis advisory committee
members Michael Mooney Steven bedrick
and Annette Totton for all their input
and feedback and also to Tammy Martin
for acting as my external Committee
Member from outside
demise finally thank you to the Caron
lab for developing the micros Shades
package and Aaron doll in particular for
her help with some of the visualizations
in this
presentation all right thank you
everyone and are there any
questions and here are my
references all right I'm going to stop
sharing my
screen